it just shows you can make a business
out of anything but you need the clouds
to appreciate the Sun now we know what
to order you we figured it out on the
second last stop and they're closed so
that was our great tour of North Sea
[Music]
good morning everybody there's Nina one
of the things I love most about you know
cruise ship is every day you wake up you
don't know what you're gonna see but I
love just opening up the blinds and poof
new city are you laughing it's true we
slept in a little bit I mean it's still
pretty tired Nina had a rough night
we're gonna grab some breakfast and get
off the hamburger I'm not excited
[Music]
all right have some good food in our
bellies time to get off the boat go
explore Hamburg hey Nina it's raining in
Hamburg we have more rain yeah I love
the rain we'd love the rain
Nina's all set for the rain we're gonna
try to find Nina an umbrella so she
doesn't have to wear the poncho it'll
add to the quality of life for Nina so
that's important right Nina all right
one more deck let's find the umbrella
[Music]
[Music]
we found in an umbrella very exciting
that's some quality umbrella life huh
how do we feel
oh man life just got amazing this is the
best day ever look we have an umbrella
and the good news is it's gonna rain for
two more days in London after we get
back so Nina has a beautiful Hamburg
this is Hamburg under umbrella beautiful
Hamburg umbrella to be happy with okay
we are now on the hunt for the most
famous fish and chips restaurant in
Hamburg called North Sea they're famous
for it and so Nina likes trying local
food that's what we're gonna do to see
if we can find the place all right we
found it North Sea does it look open but
does not look open it looks close
friends let's go check it out Oh believe
nation welcome to North Sea best fish
and chips in Hamburg and they're closed
so that was our great tour of North Sea
we're going to continue on with our day
it's ten o'clock
I guess these restaurants are open till
later which aside I don't think we back
here later in the day but we had some
fish and chips in London already and I'm
excited to try the famous what's the
famous thing it's a sausage
this famous sausage is a place called
Adele curry famous sausage we're gonna
go check that out later wait a minute
wait a minute Nina suggested going to
the other side and maybe I think it
might be open Oh Nina that's a high five
Nina Nina right there
boom good job okay let's let's let's
look at the famous fish and chips Oh
yummy
[Music]
all right let's try the beer beach
burger
German beer
[Music]
just trying name is not a big dear
friend I'm gonna enjoy this with you all
right
legendary fish and chips have arrived
looks good
time-of-use whereshegoes legendary fish
and chips Nina this is what we came for
and fresh pot rice
[Music]
those good could break yummy food now
we're going to try to find a miniature
Wunderland which is the largest in the
world indoor miniature train set
building these two stories of miniature
trains we're not really into miniature
trains but it seemed looks unique so
we're gonna check it out
[Music]
they have a bridge of locks we did this
in Paris a couple years ago or you buy a
lock and you can write something on it
and then it's supposed to symbolize your
forever love what do you think Nina
what's your favorite lock that huge fun
get that this bridge is also pretty cool
hit the files
[Music]
all right we found that the miniatur
wunderland hamburg let's go
okay so we made it in but there's a wait
it used to be two and a half hours the
weight now is about one hour so we are
number one sixth in their head number 52
so we're gonna chill in this cafe for a
bit
their economy relax get ready is it
going Nina said the surprise her with
some food so I got two cappuccinos
chocolate class on German pretzel and
German doughnut
hopefully she likes it
[Music]
okay it's now so we're number 53 and we
are 116 time to relax
[Music]
you
between 1:16 time to go in
[Music]
all right that's it we're gonna head out
it's a lot of attention to detail that
these people paid people really love
their trains to make something like this
we kind of rushed people are spending a
lot of time looking at every little
detail I'm happy that they had it me
that I'm half Italian Nina's not happy
they didn't have China it's like where's
China so miniatur wunderland get your
act together show some Chinese trains
next time support the Chinese tourists
we're going to do a quick pit stop and
then head to our next destination
waiting for Nia to get out of the
bathroom but it just shows you can make
a business out of anything like this
place is jam-packed full we have to wait
an hour to get in there's tons of people
up there then they have a restaurant and
they have a gift shop and it's lots of
other ways that they're monetizing but
it's just off of model trains as people
who had a passion for Monaco model
trains and miniature people and they
turned it into a giant successful
business so you got a passion for
something just make it the best in the
world I've got a business
we are leaving our we're leaving our
train Wonderland and we're back in the
rain I almost forgot that it was raining
outside how about you Nina representing
the belief brain well we found an even
bigger umbrella for Nina we're gonna buy
it for her I don't know if that's for
kids is that that's a grown man there
look at this you can get a surprise bag
for three euros
you know you want a surprise huh
[Music]
okay Nina Trev it's time to try the new
umbrella
you see we got
and better okay
yeah open the choco bar
that's why I can't use an umbrella cause
I got to hope the phone and the map
can't hold on they need a hand
alright take a bite I don't know I was
just hungry
I saw chocolate bar let's try it how was
it
I like a snack alright continue I'm we
stopped in at a pharmacy his name is
decided that I needed to shave that's
what she's fine where is it my new razor
she thinks this is too long yeah they
could go longer no too long me was I
happy
alright I like how they have free
wrapping paper here for you and free
Wi-Fi as well pretty cool for a
drugstore no this also a place to
recycle batteries and light bulbs very
cool
we need more this in Canada in free
water to know it's on hot water than
that
oh like you're complaining figure that
free water - I like this drugstore nice
is fresh ain't a place to park your dog
look at this dog parking inside doesn't
get wet outside very cool
[Music]
it finally stopped for a name where's
Nina where's Nina look at this smile
it's something - Nina it's not grainy
you just have to carry the umbrella very
exciting it's supposed to bring and
later on but we are gonna enjoy over
long this gap glass all right we're
gonna go down hamburg's most famous
shopping street it has this really long
name let me read it mo mo Hmong can
convert Strasse that was really bad
people called the mo so that's easy
we're gonna go down the mo when we say
Marcia team oh we haven't seen team when
a long time yeah Tina got pictures Louie
my friend is dog-sitting now Jay Rhys
was dog sitting for a little bit now
he's over with Louis and we're gonna see
him soon we're gonna see T once and Nina
every time Nina sees a dog she it's a
little emotional it's true
[Music]
Nina did you see the dog Nina yes I did
you think a Teemo be getting emotional I
[Music]
good this what did you say Nina the Sun
is out look just between the one spot
look up there there's one little spot of
no clouds
look we're squinting Nina who are
squinting this is amazing I forgot what
it's like oh no it's gone it's gone we
we forgot what it was like to have Sun
but you need the clouds to appreciate
the Sun Nina so we really appreciated
those 15 seconds of Sun and now we're
back to at least it's not raining it's
not raining that's the big win I'm
pumped for that
[Music]
look at this Nina's freaking at look at
the sky you could see you could see blue
Nina you could see blue what do you
think
let's see that happiness smile face hey
you can see blue
[Music]
you know once they go check out the
dilemma nothing for you Oh
same stuff nothing doing alright do the
lemon let's let's down guys bring some
new stuff to Europe all right let's keep
going
all right next stop is a place called
Adele curry which has it's famous for
their scurry German sausages and french
fries so we're gonna go eat enjoy sit
down relax let Nina arrest the feet and
see what Edo Curry sausages are all
about look at that son ah look at that
son Nina look at that son beautiful
[Music]
not only we want our customers to be
satisfied we want to be completely
delighted we got a ship from Louie he's
in my book here one word is one word is
delight so he's gonna love that
alright our drinks have arrived I'm
having the draft Giver
local beer Nina's having the lime the a
prepared oh it's gonna spill cheers my
friend
[Music]
you like the line better all right good
Nina like it's mixed beer now we know
what to order you we figured it out on
the second last stop we got to watch me
and eat all this stuff but we gotta
first watch you take pictures of
everything is what we came for Nina I'm
excited it's not fish I've always eaten
fish all right go
what's first try the hot dog or the
piece called the first Curie's sausage
[Music]
good
good okay you like spicy okay French
little white little sweet and spicy all
right good you got some lime gear to
wash it down with
okay french fry you got four dips tip
number one
I don't know
okay how is dip number one not great
okay
tip number two peanut okay and good good
different okay tip number three
[Music]
honey mustard okay and good maybe if you
don't look happy about any of these by
the way
pickin at your face you kind of like
angry on all the sauces like every sauce
you eat makes you angrier
Oh about the choke okay what's your
favorite one all right now guys it's
time for me to eat
so we polished off our sausages we're
working our way through the fries you
know what's your favorite honey mustard
that's one right there yeah how come
what is your what is your tummy tell you
when you have your honey mustard sauce
all right we are walking out of the idol
curry that was quality how you feelin
inna I'm good I'm not too full it just
right you had some lime beer yeah pretty
exciting
you know this is the first I heard Lena
say I like the beer so you ever buy Nina
some beer get her lined beer okay just
so you guys know it's the most she'd be
a mental check for myself and anybody
else but who knows maybe one of you guys
will meet Nina one day and say Nina can
i buy your line beer maybe maybe the
next time you know Jacob runs into Nina
and Nina forgets his name he could say
hey buy some line beer